MARTIN OMANDER: Hi.
Welcome to Root Access, the
show on Google Developers
Live about startups.
My name is Martin Omander.
And I have here Don
Dodge, longtime investor
and startup advocate.
Welcome.
DON DODGE: Great.
Thanks.
Great to be here.
MARTIN OMANDER: I see you
got the memo about blue shirt
today.
That looks good.
DON DODGE: I did, yeah.
MARTIN OMANDER: All right.
Good, good.
So Don, we've got a question
from a viewer, Jim, who said,
is it worth it as a startup
to go into an accelerator?
So let's talk a
little bit about that.
What are typically the
terms in terms of money
for going into an accelerator
when you are a startup?
DON DODGE: So Y Combinator
and Techstars and several
of the other incubators, their
models are pretty similar.
They give you $20,000
to $30,000 of cash
to basically live off from.
They require at
least two founders.
And then they take
about 5% to 6% equity
in return for that
$20,000 to $30,000.
So if you do the math,
they're valuing your company
at about $400,000 to $500,000.
So it's a pretty low valuation.
So it's something to consider.
The valuation part
of it is something
to consider if
you want to do it.
MARTIN OMANDER: Right, right.
And also, $20,000
to $30,000, you
could possibly get
that in other ways.
We've spoken to
founders here who
have got it through maxing
out credit cards and whatnot.
DON DODGE: Right.
So cash shouldn't be the reason
for doing an accelerator.
You can do that on
your credit card.
You can get friends and
family to loan you money.
So it's not about
raising the cash.
It's about the other
services that they provide.
MARTIN OMANDER: Right.
So let's talk about those.
What are those services?
DON DODGE: I think the
biggest thing that you
get from being in an
accelerator is mentorship.
So they're able to attract
mentors and experts
in the field of all
kinds of things.
So once a week, you might
have a group meeting
where an expert comes in to
talk about SEO or marketing
and how to do target
marketing, or a lawyer
to explain how term sheets work,
or a successful entrepreneur
to talk about scalability
and technical issues.
So you get a lot of
expert mentorship
that you probably wouldn't
have access to otherwise.
So that's number one.
Number two, you get
to focus on what
is your minimum viable product.
What are those key
features that have
got to be there in order to
launch and be successful?
And that's a tough question,
because, typically, it's
not obvious what those
things should be.
So you'll get a lot
of advice about how
to do your minimum
viable product.
The third thing you get
is a lot of training
on how to pitch, how to put
together your pitch deck,
what issues you
should cover, and then
how to pitch in
front of an audience,
or how to pitch
in front of a VC.
And if you haven't
done that before,
that's a pretty big deal.
The last thing you get
is, typically, they'll
have an investor day or demo
day at the end of the session.
And that's where you
get exposure and access
to lots and lots of investors
and maybe some press.
So that's four things you get
that are a pretty big deal.
There are other ways to do it.
But they're very, very good
at delivering those services.
MARTIN OMANDER: Right.
So if you're a
startup and you're
thinking about whether to go
into an accelerator or not,
whether you can provide
these things yourself,
what's the thought process one
should go through as a founder?
DON DODGE: Well, there are
counter cases and examples
for each one of those four
benefits that I mentioned.
There are other ways
to get those benefits.
That said, getting
into Y Combinator
or Techstars is
very, very difficult.
They accept 1% to 2% of
the companies that apply.
So it's sort of like
getting into college.
Should you go to college?
Well, yeah.
If you can, you probably should.
Should you go to
Harvard or Stanford?
Absolutely, if you can.
But that's not a prerequisite.
It's not, if I can't get
into Harvard or Stanford,
I'm going to be a failure.
Obviously not.
You don't need to go
to college at all.
There are always different
ways to do things.
So if you can get into an
accelerator like that, sure.
If you can't, there are
other ways to raise money.
You can raise them from
friends and family.
There are other ways
to get mentorship.
You can bring on an adviser.
And rather than give up
5% or 6% of your company,
maybe give up a half a
percent to an adviser.
There are other
ways to raise money.
Your advisers or other
founders can introduce you
to VCs or Angels.
And you can raise
money that way.
So there's an alternative to
every one of these things.
I think being in
an accelerator just
makes it all happen faster.
And the single biggest
thing you really
get out of an accelerator is
it's like being in boot camp.
You have other founders who are
going through the same things
that you are, trying to
solve the same problems.
And you learn a lot
from them and together.
And you probably
make progress faster.
MARTIN OMANDER: Go faster.
And speed is important, right?
DON DODGE: It is.
That's why they call
them accelerators.
MARTIN OMANDER: Accelerators.
Ah, good.
So at what point is your
company, your startup,
ready to go into an accelerator?
Should you have a product?
Should you have a team?
Should you have customers?
What's the right place?
DON DODGE: Yeah, good point.
So there are incubators.
And there are accelerators.
So incubators, like
Techstars and Y Combinator,
assume that you
don't have a product.
So you probably have an idea.
You have two founders.
You might have a prototype or
maybe even a working model.
But you don't yet
have a product.
So that's why they call them
incubators, because you're
going from nothing to
something in an incubator.
If you have a product, you have
a team, and it's out there,
and you're looking
to accelerate,
then you go to an accelerator.
Sometimes we use those
words interchangeably.
But they're different.
Incubators are for
starting from nothing
and incubating it to an idea
that's ready to accept money.
Accelerators are you
already have a product.
You have a team.
You might have a
little bit of money.
And you're looking
to accelerate.
So they'll give you some office
space and a place to expand.
They'll give you
different services
that allow you to
accelerate your plans faster
than you normally would.
So I would say you can do an
incubator or an accelerator
at any time.
It just depends on
what services you need
and what stage you're at.
MARTIN OMANDER: Great.
Thank you.
Excellent advice, Don.
DON DODGE: Great.
Great to be here.
MARTIN OMANDER: So if
you are a cloud developer
and you want to run your
application on Google
infrastructure, you should try
out the Google Cloud Platform.
And right now, if you're
a Root Access viewer,
you can get a $2,000 credit to
get started on the platform.
The details are on your screen.
Please keep the comments
coming in on the YouTube video.
And we'll address
them, like we did
this one in future episodes.
Thank you.
See you next time.